je viens d'une lignée de constructeurs
de ponts déjà mon grand père aux états
unis construisez des ponts dans l'ohio
ensuite mes parents construisez aussi
des ponts cette fois ci entre les
afro-américains et les blancs mais aussi
très grand pont entre français et
américains
g je suis con sus aux gt conçue à paris
je suis né à chicago j'ai grandi et je
suis revenu en france où je vis depuis
fort longtemps
mais pour entrer dans le vif du sujet
pour moi sortir du cadre c'est dessiner
sur les murs depuis que je dessine sur
les murs je suis la plus heureuse des
femmes
forcément mais comment suis-je arriver
là au fait pendant très longtemps
j'essaie de construire des ponts entre
ma passion les arts plastiques et tout
le reste tout le reste
et au fait depuis très longtemps je
m'adonne à la peinture et
malheureusement je suis très très très
déçu du business model de l'artiste est
déçu et pourquoi je suis déçu parce
qu'au fait on travaille seul isolé n'est
pas en soi une mauvaise chose mais leur
rôle de l'artiste dans la société
occidentale extrêmement limité
limite mais j'avais toujours quand même
une intuition profonde que le langage
visuel l'image allait jouer un rôle
nouveau est crucial dans notre société
et je n'étais pas la seule à me poser
des questions comme ça parce que très
loin d'ici
en californie dans les années 70 un
monsieur qui s'appelle david si bête
voilà david si bête a aussi une
intuition géniale kraft ses amis
architectes et designers
il s'est rendu compte qu'on pouvait
réfléchir en dessinant sur les murs et
donc il a dessiné sa les murs avec ses
amis dans les entreprises dans toutes
sortes de contexte du coup enfin on
s'est retrouvé avec un langage visuel
simple des métaphores visuelles qui
permettait à tout le monde de mieux
travailler ensemble du mieux réfléchir
ensemble
alors là tout allait bien pour lui mais
moi j'étais très loin de là bas c'était
à san francisco j'étais à paris à 5000
km de là du coup j'ai quand même eu
beaucoup de chance j'ai une amie qui
s'appelle anita merci de tanit a
d'ailleurs qui a qui a été dans une
conférence internationale où l'a vu
quelqu'un faire de la récolte graphique
sur un grand mur pendant cette
conférence
ella a pris des photos elle m'a envoyé
un email et là j'ai immédiatement
reconnu ma vocation tardive qui
l'énergie tout d'un coup
énergie tout d'un coup donc j'avais
découvert cette belle chose que david
guetta découverte qui s'appelle l'as far
si les stations visuel
maintenant il ya le mot facile les gens
peuvent être assurés donc au fait qui se
passe c'est que on se demande pourquoi
c'est important tout ça pour quoi
dessiner à rémy bon en entreprise ou
ailleurs c'est passé comme vous
n'arrêtez pas d'entendre dans cette
salle aujourd'hui nous sommes tous en
train de vivre des transformations
majeures
pardon transformation
du fait de ces transformations nous
avons une espèce de grand vide devant
nous un espèce d'inconnus on sait pas
vraiment comment ont pu aller au delà où
nous sommes vers laon nourriront d'être
du coup on est tous un peu obligés de
commencer à construire des ponts non
seulement dans le travail mais aussi
même dans notre vie personnelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les dessins
est là pour nous aider
donc le dessin c'est notre héritage a
tous pensé à votre enfance tous les
enfants dessinent naturellement et puis
on apprend à lire et à écrire dessiner
en écoutant le prof cette vente est
interdite et qu'est-ce que vous avez
souvent tendue même peut-être que vous
êtes nuls en dessin c'est bien dommage
mais heureusement à science est là pour
nous aider à passer le pont vers le
dessin de nouveau juste quelques
chiffres toujours plaisir savez-vous
quelle gribouillant réunion s'augmente
faute rétention de 29 passant d'un tiers
savez vous qu'un concept en images avec
un mot ici fois plus mémorisable un
concept que avec le mot c'est pas pour
rien que je dessine en puce savez vous
que depuis 2007 sur internet
la quantité d'informations la quantité
d'informations visuelles a augmenté de
10 mille pour cent
c'est quand même énorme ce qui prouve
que nous sommes encore en train de nous
rappeler d'un fait primordial c'est que
nous sommes des animaux visuel
animaux visuel animaux visuel donc pour
que vraiment vous soyez convaincus à
fond je vous invite à aller dans vos
sacs chercher vos carnets et vos feutre
ou stylo je ne sais plus quand vous avez
alesi action
tout le monde est bon stylos crayons
tout est bon ok pour fait moi je vais
vous faire faire un petit voyage parce
que le dessin fait qu'est ce qu'on fait
on voyage à travers la feuille on va
passer le pont du dessin ensemble voilà
notre voyage et pour ce faire
comme on a très peu de temps j'ai quand
même vous faire dessiner quelque chose
de très intéressant les personnages on
va commencer avec ce qu'on appelle la
star invention de six bêtes
voilà la petite star 1 pi ca allez-y
dessinée non mais je me donne du mal
vous aussi allez un petit bras ty jambes
deuxième bande petit bras petit rayon
là vous avez déjà un personnage qu'on va
appeler le star people en anglais mais
si ça me branche pas trop les tapis paul
ce n'est pas grave parce qu'il y en a
d'autres
donc oui ce que c'est ça ça c est ce qu
en anglais squido est un gribouillage et
quand on a un gribouillage il suffit de
rajouter des trucs habituels une tête et
un bras un autre voix des petites jambes
et là quelques rayons et vous avez
encore un personnage et bientôt vous
allez sentir une affinité vis-à-vis
d'une de ses personnages parce qu'un
troisième on appelait ça le peuple du
carré vous imaginez tout de suite
commencé à se passer petit carré pas
difficile petite tête
petit bras
vous avez dessiné tout ça j'espère l'ail
et bien bravo
ok donc c'est bien amusant tout ça mais
comment dire il ya quand même l'idée
aussi qu'on puisse non seulement décider
pour soi mais aussi avec les autres pour
mieux penser réfléchir et agir ensemble
tout en gardant en tête une sorte de
vision globale parce qu'au fait quand
vous dessiner avec d'autres personnes
ce qui est important ce n'est pas
tellement le fait que vous allez
produire une image fini produit final au
fait ce qui est important c'est comment
les participants du groupe travaillent
ensemble en dessinant en interagissant
avec leurs défunts de manière justement
à travailler de façon plus collaborative
je vais vous donner un exemple pour le
compte d'une grande banque
j'avais été amenés à accompagner pour
une grande banque
une sorte de grands projets de
transformation digitale tout le monde
est là dedans
et du coup tous les équipes devaient
réfléchir ensemble sur leur ligne de vie
sur trois ans donc on avait un projet
avec une ligne de vie de trois ans il
fallait le faire de façon métaphorique
il fallait qu'ils trouvent leur
métaphore donc on avait des équipes ans
dans la jungle qui faisait du surf qui
faisait un voyage en mer qui faisait
décoller tout le temps des avions et je
vous présente aussi les jumeaux haïti
net et pépito haïti finances donc ça
c'était le travail de co création de
l'équipe
et puis après on m'a demandé de faire ce
qu'on appelle une story map
donc là je repris le travail de création
du groupe et j'en ai fait un visuel qui
leur promet de garder en tête de leur
vision globale mais
tout ça c'est bien beau mais la
transformation commence quand même par
soi même
vous allez reprendre aux feuilles on va
encore dessiner ensemble près courage
c'est très facile
donc on va faire une espèce de rock on
va rentrer dans les profondeurs de nous
mêmes donc je vous invite à fermer les
yeux d'abord respirer ouvrez les yeux et
noté le mot colère de ce côté là c'est
bon maintenant vous allez dessiner la
colère mais sans faire d'image juste
avec des formes et des lignes et de
façon coléreux
allez-y je vais faire aussi
t'es bon regardez par les voisins vous
fait pour vous ok ok maintenant doit
fermer les yeux pour reprendre ses
esprits après cette bouffée de colère
maintenant vous allez écrire le mot paix
de l'autre côté
re santé la paix est encore une fois
vous avez dessiné la paix paisiblement
sans image pas de symboles je veux pas
voir d'oiseaux fait ça avec des lignes
et des formes
j'y vais aussi on y va
c'est bon
excellent alors puisqu'on est dans les
ponts sans arrive on va décimer trois
flèches
et en fait maintenant vous allez essayer
d'imaginer comment vous faites pour
aller la colère au calme à la paix à la
sérénité et vous allez nommer les trois
flèches d'accord on y va
très bon alors maintenant montrer vos
dessins regarder les dessins que vous
avez fait ainsi monter les dessins vous
regardez bien je vois pas grand chose à
cause des lumières a fait mieux
oh là là bravo c'est pas beau ça
merci